for me coming to business school the
strength of the community really
mattered from day one people were just
very open and excited to meet everyone
the size of the program is what allows
us to have like really meaningful
connections I can truly say that I know
at least like one or two facts about
every single classmate in our class of
400 which is like something that it's
truly unique and you wouldn't be able to
get other programs so the bbsa is the
black business Students Association and
it's really meant to form a home base or
a community for black students at the
Stanford GSB and even for me personally
they've been kind of just my rock my
ground somewhere where you can just be
your full complete authentic self and
just really develop a second family the
bbsa is one of the Affinity groups at
the GSP and it's a space for black
students to come into Community with one
another not only Bond over shared
experiences like of Blackness in the
world and Blackness at the GSB but then
to also learn from black alumni black
Business Leaders and connect with other
Affinity groups one thing that has
really inspired me about the bbsa
community is just how open and authentic
everyone is they really care about you
as a person they care about not only
like your professional well-being but
also your emotional well-being and
making sure that you're growing as a
holistic person and I think that just
sense of care is something that really
stands out to me as the part of the bbsa
community my favorite thing about vbsa
is how people just go to bat for other
bbsa members the bbsa for me has been
somewhat of a safe space within the GSB
it's a space where immediately I was
able to let my guard down and be who I
was and connect with some people who I
knew before and some people who I didn't
but who I knew shared an experience with
me like walking through Palo Alto or
through Stanford as a black person is
just a different experience and having a
group of people that gets that as you go
through ups and downs of living life as
a black American has been really really
important to me even though the
community may be smaller than other
institutions I think one of the things I
really appreciate is the depth of our
connections and the depth of our
relationships are kind of far beyond
what I might have imagined if you're
joining the bbsa I'd say there are lots
of formal and informal events so some of
my favorite ones is the annual bbsa
Retreat we also do lots of just casual
hangouts or kickbacks whether in
people's homes or somewhere on campus I
threw a black ghost brunch and people
were just that excited and ready to
engage from the start and for me that
just reinforced that this was gonna be a
good experience this past weekend had
the bbsa black leadership conference and
that was a really that's like our
Hallmark event and so it was really nice
to bring together alumni and current
bbsa members and really just not only
experience like the joy of can acting
but also have the opportunity to learn
from each other listen to panels and
hear both from the successes and the
failures of those who may have come
before us we had 16 speakers come some
of them are alums and it was all in one
day we had two at a conference in a Gala
and it was so magical that the topic was
black Futures and so it was a day where
we could really think about and really
imagine how black people are going to be
the future and part of the future but
also how we're going to shape the future
my first advice to prospective students
is Reach Out attend events get connected
with people trust that you belong in all
the spaces that you are invited into and
also trust your expertise your talents
your wisdom and know that you can find a
home here at Stanford I'm lucky that I
found it and I'm lucky that I get to
experience it and I just hope that more
people take the leap and come here and
join us
thank you
[Music]